c'est l'une des nouveautés de 2023 la
fin de la vaisselle jetable dans les
fast food pour lutter contre le
gaspillage problème chez McDo les
clients se servent et repartent avec les
Verts les boîtes de frites ou de nuggets
le tout en plastique il paraît que c'est
collector et on se retrouve donc avec
avec McDonald's qui se retrouve à faire
des vidéos mais comme à des enfants pour
dire attention la vaisselle réutilisable
il faut la rendre un McDonald's et pas
repartir avec bah les Français sont
impayables alors entre 15 et 40% de
lave-vaisselle a disparu selon les
restaurants la vaisselle disparaît soit
par étourderie parce qu'on a pris
l'habitude pendant des années de jeter
l'intégralité du plateau salle à la
poubelle directement soit à cause du vol
certaines chaînes de restauration rapide
on fait un gros effort sur le design
c'est vrai que c'est ces nouveaux
contenants ils ne sont plutôt cool sur
le truc rouge chez McDo comme toi donc
ont eu envie de les emporter je rappelle
aux gens que c'est du vol que ils
commettent un délit en faisant ça donc
voilà là ça c'est la première chose non
c'est pas la morale
tu sais c'est tout simplement du droit
on veut se donner bonne conscience en
disant ben on va faire de on va on va
arrêter le jetable et cetera si les gens
sont bêtes au point de voler la
vaisselle réutilisable ben on fera plus
rien au bout d'un moment vous êtes dans
quelle catégorie vous étourdi ou voleur
voleur enfin pour ça je veux dire
McDo de frites je n'ai pas vu de plaque
j'ai pas réussi à l'attribuer à un
designer on a notamment Léon Martin qui
a fait des meubles
de diamètre plusieurs kilos de
frangipane et de pâte feuilletée et
pourtant les boulangers craignent de ne
pas avoir leur part du gâteau rétréci
par les factures d'énergie ils étaient
reçu à l'Élysée pour la traditionnelle
galette des rois Emmanuel Macron a tenu
à les rassurer il y en a qui ont eu des
x 5 ou x 10
et ça c'est pas normal et donc quel que
soit votre augmentation 40% va être pris
en charge par ces dispositifs l'année où
on a inscrit la baguette au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO si on n'aide pas les
boulanger alors là vraiment c'est ce
serait la politique de gribouille dans
les yeux de baguettes bien
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entrée entre les artistes
est là coucou
il y a sûrement un jeu de mots mais
alors je suis tellement nulle pour ça
mais je vois pas entrer des artistes aux
arrêts là non il y a pas de genoux c'est
une image inédite et historique
le pape en exercice François la main
posée sur le cercueil de son
prédécesseur Benoît XVI pour une
dernière prière
jamais dans l'histoire de l'Église
catholique un pape n'avait présidé les
obsèques d'un autre
sous la brume près de 50 000 personnes
se sont rassemblés place Saint-Pierre
moment de recueillement à l'instant en
direct de Rome et je vous propose de
précisément marquer ce moment de
recueillement pendant quelques secondes
afin de préparer mon serment je n'ai pas
fermé l'oeil de la nuit je me posais
bien trop de questions
au petit matin Dieu est apparu et il m'a
donné la solution
aussitôt vers l'église j'ai couru parlé
à mes fidèles sur ce temps
que ta joie soit entière en entendant sa
voix maintenant et pour toujours
Muriel vous êtes magnifique vraiment
c'est très beau non c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
quand j'étais lycéen je voulais un
métier qui bouge vous êtes pompier ou
GIGN ou un petit qui sauve quoi ma
chérie prête ça sauve aussi un peu de
façon je suis rentré au séminaire à 21
ans je t'ai redonné à 28 vous avez une
vie sentimentale avant bien sûr ben oui
bien sûr et cette vie sentimentale elle
ne vous manque pas en fait tu veux sans
ni en couple ni célibataire c'est que
mon cœur est pris vous voyez j'ai donné
ma vie au Seigneur et je me sens pas
frustré ou je vis une histoire d'amour
d'une certaine façon sortez il y a une
alerte amour une alerte le sentiment
merci de sortir merci sortez sortez à
demain sortez vite
dépêchez-vous l'amour n'attend pas
dépêchez-vous je vois que mademoiselle
se
sentait un verre d'eau ou un site parce
que
il y a aucun problème allez-y parce que
sinon vous allez tomber je sais comment
ça se passe moi ici on a justement pas
pris le petit déjeuner on l'a pris trop
tôt et puis on reste beaucoup longtemps
je me trompe pas elle se sentait pas
aucun problème voilà
j'ai l'oeil
j'avais raison
je suis contente d'être là
j'aime pas quand il y a beaucoup de
monde ça m'oppresse
aussi
[Musique]
c'est que ça il y a rien du tout